talk a little bit about why you wanted
to do this and just where this came from
for both of you God well it started
actually kind of for me it started from
you because I'm Haley and I met at the
Canada Walk of Fame ceremony and she
introduced me to grace ballin and like a
lot of people who met grace bone I fell
in love with grace bone and I remember
you know and I say this with all due
respect I have anxiety about going
places let her you know events like like
those sorts of things like the Canon
Walk of Fame and I really felt like when
I left there and I got home the next day
I said I fell like the reason I was
there was to meet grace and and I have
Haley to thank for that him yeah I think
you know it's you get an opportunity in
the position I guess that that were in
to meet a lot of kids and and do things
like that and definitely grace touched
my life and in a big way and you know
the impact and the long-lasting good
that she's gonna do you know she's not
with us anymore has been incredible I
mean what Ryan's doing and just
galvanizing people from all over the
world really it's it's been pretty neat
it's pretty wild to see what one kid can
yeah do you know that touched you so
much I mean I met her briefly that day
and she was very special but for you
what was it well she just she just had
this kind of I mean I I hate to be that
guy but she had this in her grace that
was just so beautiful and um and she's
you know just to be I met a family Greg
and Andrea her parents and Mackenzie her
sister and and um you know they just
just I just saw how what she was going
through affected everyone around her and
and how inspiring she was for everyone
else in ordered it was sort of draw them
from rest to effort to actually do
something and you know we grace was kind
of a catalyst for me because I I had no
idea but I was about to step into to
working on on Deadpool which as a
character was cancer and suddenly all
these kids were reaching out to me who
had cancer who looked up to this
character who sort of for lack of a more
eloquent way to describe it so flipped
cancer the bird and you know I suddenly
started meeting kids from all over the
place and we're hosting them on set and
you know you start to see these guys and
you think about how lucky and how
privileged we are not only to be in the
positions we are in which we can sort of
have a pretty loud megaphone to raise
awareness for this but also that you
know I'm one of the lucky people that my
kids are healthy and and well and and
you know I can't help but project that
onto my own life so I want to do
everything I can to to help people who
are going through this and and and and
make sure that we eradicate this as much
as possible so and I think what's
amazing about this whole day is you
called sick kids and said I want to come
I will take care of my flight I will
take care of this you called your friend
this is something you kind of curated
and said use me what can I do yeah I
didn't you know I I guess I don't know
how else he do stuff like I guess he you
know you wait for people to come to you
if you do that you're gonna you know
wait a long time so the I I saw the vs.
campaign yes it kids was doing it I
thought I was so powerful yeah and so
moving and I got really really close
with another kid who unfortunately isn't
with us anymore but Connor McGrath in
Edmonton and and you know I just sort of
wanted to use that energy in that that
the the anguish that came from losing
that particular kid in as well as grace
and and and use it and turn it into an
energy of change or something that was
positive so yeah I called them and said
you know what can I do and I'll do
anything let me know let me know how I
can help and they thankfully responded
with we have this great campaign going
right now and I watched it we learned
all about it and it was fascinating and
then I called this one right here
yesterday and she was just like oh man I
mean this thing in Toronto tomorrow
where are you she's like Calgary I was
like oh okay and then the next email you
sent me was I'm on my way yes amazing
how does this changed you as as parents
I mean meeting these kids getting
involved with their families and then
realizing when you go home to your own
children that doesn't go away
yeah those thoughts well I mean my son
is 16 and he was very very sick when he
was very young and so I have a little
glimpse into what a parent goes through
but nothing you know like what many of
these parents have faced losing a child
and so I think what what you realize is
kids are so tough they're way tougher
than adults they have unbelievable pain
tolerance and sometimes you don't even
know that they're hurting until you know
they are very very second so just you
know to to look as a parent have a
healthy child of my own and be all you
think about is just how grateful you are
because it you know you just never know
and I think that you know we have to do
what we can to help those that aren't so
fortunate mm-hmm and for you Ryan I mean
you're have young ones and and you know
202 right yeah you know I obviously
gratitude is the first and foremost one
I'm just grateful that they're there
here and with us and you know and then
secondarily obviously that they're
healthy and happy and but you know I'm
also I also want to make sure that
there's there are things that are in
place like Sick Kids Foundation that you
know for if anything should happen to
anybody out there that is experiencing
something that you know the grace or
they Connor or so many other kids that
I've met have gone through that that
they have a place to go they have place
to go that really is more of a holistic
approach that truly care and you know I
I just find that incredibly motivating I
think that's a fantastic place to put
your energy in and and for me that's you
know it's been a privilege to be able to
just jump in to be able to call these
guys and have them organize something as
massive is what we're doing today
yeah it's a feat unto itself so it's
amazing and I heard the only thing on
your rider was that you needed to be
home to tuck your kids in tonight yeah
that's about it yeah I think that's it
that's an all right thing I think that
it's the best rider I've ever heard in
my life yeah I think yeah yeah most
showbiz people it's it's hard drugs but
for me yeah that's it yeah that's it
yeah